[Music]
healing is an unending process and and
that's okay you're not alone you can
come back from anything you know you can
hit rock bottom and still make something
beautiful out of it we are given a
choice in those dark moments in the
moments of tragedy will you choose to
allow it to make you stronger or will
you choose to allow it to break you
beyond
repair one of the most beloved guests in
the history of this podcast is ultr
Runner Tom rivs what he learned from a
near fatal brush with a rare form of
lung cancer and his remarkable return to
both life and sport has and continues to
touch millions of people yeah I'm just
stoked that I'm just still around you
know if you count yourself among those
impacted by his powerful story so
beautifully told then you are going to
love Steph kachad doll in equally
Soulful gifted writer who shares her
life and the experience of almost losing
her husband Tommy in her stunning and
very intimate New York Times
best-selling Memoir everything all at
once this conversation is really about
all the big things it's about trauma and
grief and suffering it's about faith
it's about rebellion but it's also about
how to recognize gratitude love and
beauty amid the tragedy while also
holding space for emotions like pain
anger and sorrow in other words how to
allow everything all at once I was very
moved by Steph's book her openness and
vulnerability in this conversation is
powerful I think you'll find it quite
impactful uh and it's all coming up so
uh here we go this is me and Steph
kachad
doll Steph it's so nice to meet you I've
been looking forward to this for such a
long time so welcome to the show I can't
wait to get into your life this
fantastic ftic new book that is now a
New York Times bestseller
congratulations that's amazing
everything all at once the process of
writing it I'm interested in what that
was like for you and if you had any
additional sort of discoveries about
yourself in life as a result of of of
doing that that perhaps you wouldn't
have had short of the writing itself
yeah um writing this book was really
really difficult for me um I I had to he
well it's an ongoing process I was
healing from the trauma of what happened
to me in real time as I was writing so I
think that's why the book is so raw and
um because I was still in that
emotionally raw State when I was writing
it I was deeply depressed when I was
writing it as well I feel like it was
the come down from this post-traumatic
stress you know experience that I was
having and I think that comes out in the
pages and even when I read it now I
can't access that same depth of emotion
and I think I had to write it in that
state um for it to be as true as it was
when I was writing it yeah I would
suspect five years from now 10 years
from now you may reflect back on it and
have a different relationship with it or
experience and I think the process of
then putting a book out into the world
means that you sit down with people like
me and you talk a lot about what's in
the book and and I think that in and of
itself then continues to inform your own
kind of Journey of self- understanding
like it will continue to reveal newer
and newer layers of that yeah well what
I'm one of the the most important things
that I'm learning and and learned
throughout writing the book is is that
healing is never ending it's it's an
unending process and and that's okay and
and there's no finality in my book
because I was realizing there's no
finality to grief or um and and I'm sure
I'll look back on this book like you
said in 5 and 10 years and kind of look
back on myself with almost like a
childlike fondness you know that that I
was that I was so new in my healing yeah
and I think that's a beautiful thing to
accept that we're just all on this
healing journey and there's no there's
no Final Destination you know it's just
ongoing yeah I think it's a beautiful
and healthy response to it this book is
actually in extrapolation of an earlier
book that you were writing about you
confronting and and making peace with
and and healing the experience of losing
your father to lung cancer a story that
you thought was complete at the time and
it was only through what happened with
rivs that you realize like that was just
you know sort of pre- intermission right
and the story still had had had you know
much to tell you I think if you had put
that book out um prior you would have
missed the magic uh and and all the
messiness and the pain of course of what
you of what you experience that now
gives you kind of a gravitas to share
from a new level and The Narrative of
the book is structured such that you
toggle back and forth between that
original story which is kind of a a
linear chronology of your life peppered
in between with chapters about what is
going on with rivs and how that reflects
upon
experiences you had as a younger person
yeah well that first half of the book so
all of the even chapters are um the
roughly the book that I wrote um from
one the past decade and I actually
finished that version of the book and I
called it This Is Where I Leave You
because I actually thought that I was
leaving my grief behind that that grief
was something that could be left behind
and um I felt like as though I had
finished grieving the death of My Father
which now to me is just really
interesting or even comical that I
thought that you can finish grieving and
when ribs got sick that narrative
obviously got cracked wide open and um
one of the most impactful things that I
learned about myself is that I hadn't
finished grieving the death of my father
because you never finish grieving and
and in order to truly accept the
wholeness of myself I had to accept that
that void left by my father's death
would always be there and and that's
okay and and then it became what tools
do you use to to fill that void that are
not self-destructive and that's that's
the journey I'm on now currently I'm
still real time I'm I'm that's where I'm
at because I I learned that to accept
that that hole or that void inside of me
and now I'm trying to figure out ways
to to not fill it but to to just deal
with it um in in in more productive ways
yeah you're a Seeker you know you're
somebody who at a very early age was
looking for answers in in lots of
different ways not all not always so
healthy right you know ran away from
home at 16 there's drugs and alcohol
involved um you grappling with your
relationship to being raised Mormon and
what is spirituality mean what does
prayer mean things like this y um you
were always looking for answers
um and I think part of this narrative is
that you're running away in the
searching right you think you're running
towards answers but you're actually
running away from what's right in front
of you which is confronting the truth of
your father's passing and what that
meant to you and how that affected you
and and trying to figure out you know
what is God mean and what what is what
is what is my purpose and all these sort
of unprogram you know some of the the um
the Dogma that was instilled in you from
a religious perspective as a young
person and it
required what happened to rivs in order
for you to stop because you couldn't
turn away yeah for the first time in
your life and you had to confront it and
it's just [__] crazy because your dad
passes from lung cancer and then rivs
gets lung I mean you cannot script this
or make this up it's like this insane
like Collision of you know truth that
the Universe conspired to put in your
path in order for your own
self-discovery and and growth yeah well
there's a part in my book where um we I
think it' been two days since we got
rib's final diagnosis which was the lung
cancer and I was with my sister and we
were just floating in an Airbnb pool
kind of in this Purgatory of waiting for
me to be able to visit ribs in the
hospital and I said the words aloud I
said my husband has [__] lung cancer
and we just laughed and laughed and
laughed it was just this cathartic just
recognizing this cruel irony um that
like you said just almost like the
universe just shaking me saying you need
to learn this lesson and I don't
necessarily think that things happen for
a reason I I don't like to think that my
dad died for a reason or that rivs got
sick for a reason I think that's
dangerous teritory for me personally but
looking back I can assign meaning to
what happened for my own self that's a
choice yeah that's the choice I made was
to say my dad died um that was just
purely tragic but from his passing and
from the response that his grief made me
feel in the ways that I acted taught me
better and equipped me to better deal
with my husband's diagnosis and then my
husband's diagnosis in turn in this
cyclical nature helped me heal from my
father's passing right and so it was
this in very very it felt like this
Cosmic um I I felt like I was on a train
and everything that was happening during
that year and a half was a stop that I
was supposed to get off at and then get
back on the train that's how it felt
right with the question where is the
opportunity for my own personal
Evolution and all of this in the midst
of the chaos and pain and everything
else MH and I think also what we talked
about me searching for um for answers
and searching for meaning I during my
adolescence and everything in the wake
of my father's death what I came to find
was that I had been searching outside
myself for this plation or for the
answers I mean of course but and and
especially because I was raised Mormon
and so I was taught that power lives
outside of us that we submit to the
power and I think that's good in some
ways cuz it brings humility and you know
lessening of the ego but but what I
found was that I held the power inside
of me and that I could find the healing
and it wasn't an outside Source it was
it was innate in me I was born with that
power and it was just learning how to
access it and and it was love that
taught me that yeah the first stop being
Mormonism and the final stop on that
train tour being being rivs thinking
that the answers that you were seeking
could be found in this relationship with
this extraordinary human being and not
until um the kind of frailness uh you
know of of his physical self became
evident were you able
to understand that he he was not your
solution either right that it was it's
between you and you yeah and that was
that was a really sad Reckoning because
it wasn't until he was sedated and in a
coma essentially that I realized that I
had been blaming him for a lot of my
deficiencies because he didn't heal me
he didn't make me whole therefore there
was something wrong with him and I only
as I was sitting by his bed was I
realizing how many how many moments and
events I had blamed him for when it was
really all my responsibility my
happiness was only mine he couldn't give
me that happiness that wholeness and I
had been blaming him and and part of
this urgency of wanting him to wake up
was for me to apologize for saying I'm
sorry I expected you to heal me what an
untenable demand you know like how but I
think a lot of us do that I and I think
that came from the wound of my father's
death of this of this you know feeling
like you need to stay here because
you're going to replace my dad you know
which is and thinking that you had
resolved that grief and overcome that
trauma only to discover that that you
hadn't right y I've been thinking a lot
about that that's beautifully said um
and I again I made some notes that I
that I want to share so I'm going to
refer to them um I was thinking about
what you just said uh and also
reflecting on a recent personal
experience that I had and I posted this
thing on social media yesterday about
trauma and I said I'm convinced that one
of if not the most important keys to
Living Well requires redress and healing
of past child past or childhood traumas
basically arresting the dysfunctional
behaviors that we've inherited by our
ancestry that recur unconsciously and
reactively adopting new healthier ways
of living and instilling these more
adaptive patterns as default settings in
the next generation is the most worthy
and esteemable pursuit and the path to
freedom and as I think
about your story and thinking about the
many ways in which you were kind of
running away from yourself and your pain
through religion prayer Geographics
drugs you're dabbling with sobriety and
AA and
psychedelics um but the truth and and
ultimately the LIE is
that this soless that you end up
experiencing and believing that
everything you were looking for you you
end up finding in Ribs Right This empath
to use your own phrase this very
sensitive human being um who's kind of
like from an outsider perspective almost
like a bodh SATA like figure you know
he's incredibly charismatic he's Larger
than Life he's very strong and and
seemingly Invincible this protector but
he also exudes this really beautiful
quality of love and you know benevolence
and and kindness that um ends up not
just comforting you but comforting a lot
of people uh but that is very bright
sunlight right that ends up that power
ends up eclipsing your own power and
ultimately Works AC cross purposes with
your own growth it prevents and delays
you from confronting yourself
confronting your past it arrests your
healing it keeps you
disconnected and you can choose
to uh believe or or um perceive in this
whole experience that on some
level his disease is this gift that he's
giving you for your own Evolution
because finally like I said earlier you
can't for the first time you can't run
away You're compelled to confront your
past and heal it and and ultimately
become whole and in the telling of this
story in this book you are passing this
on you're not only passing it on in the
way that you're parenting your daughters
so that they don't sort of inherit the
same behavior response to trauma that
you did but by sharing it with your
words you have this vehicle to empower
other people which is just you know like
that's it man like that's the [__] right
that's what we're here to do we're here
to grow evolve and then share what we
learned along the way it's still a a
daily practice though it's not as though
I figured it out because I wrote this
book and therefore I am now healed from
codependency and you know all of these
things that I still have to make a
conscious choice to not let the trauma
child inside me act out because she's
still there we never get rid of our
trauma selves I don't think um but
accepting and recognizing that that's
what's causing us to act out in certain
ways is liberating for me because then I
can I can feel her yelling and being
insecure and then I can recognize her
rather than just pretend it's someone
else's problem um and and so that's
that's a daily practice that I am trying
to work at is hearing my trauma self and
then acting in a way that's not blaming
or destructive but that's part of
everything you know all at once right
it's the it's the full spectrum of
emotions and learning how to be in a
place of self-acceptance with those
rather than trying to hold yourself up
to some perfectionist standard of how
you're supposed to respond to a
difficult situation absolutely and not
fighting against it I think I felt I I
tried so hard my whole life to fight
against depression fight against anxiety
to to battle it and push it away and it
isn't until I'm beginning now to just
allow it and accept it and almost make
it my friend and and my teacher and my
companion that I'm able to move forward
rather than staying stuck in the same
patterns yeah and that might have come
across in some of those AA meetings you
went to when you were in your early 20s
or
whatever yeah surrender surrender I mean
but that's the thing is and and also
what I'm learning is that truth is found
everywhere you know truth is found in
the Mormon religion and in AA and in
psychedelics it's found everywhere it's
just you find your Avenue that resonates
most with you and but we're all saying
the same thing we're all saying the same
thing you know and and I think that's
that's beautiful when you can recognize
that we're all just little trauma kids
trying to trying to heal in this life
yeah it's your story is unique to you
and yet it's kind of the oldest story
it's like I ran around the world looking
for answers only to arrive back home and
realize they were within me all the time
yeah I mean it is and that that's what
it's I feel like pain is universal but
we experience it so personally and it
feels so personal to us and part of the
reason I wrote this book was I wanted
people to know that you're not alone
like I I gave every greedy detail to let
people know that whatever they're doing
to cope with their their tragedy or
their trauma that it if if they could
use it as a vehicle to self-improvement
then you can come back from anything you
know you can hit rock bottom like I more
or less did and and still make something
beautiful out of it it's one thing to
you know navigate the challenges of a
loved one who's succumbing to cancer and
it's another thing entirely to do that
under the public eye like you're both
you and your husband are both people who
are sort of welln
um and I'm wondering how that impacted
how you were dealing with it privately
and then realizing like there's a public
out there that wants to be apprised of
what's Happening Moment by moment and
the tension between trying to protect
your family and and you know navigate a
very personal thing with the demands of
people that are in some kind of
parasocial relationship with you that
you've never met yeah well and I think
that was heightened by the fact that it
was Co so everyone was isolated and
lonely and living virtually so everyone
was in these parasocial relationships at
the time and so um I think that just
heightened and intensified the
connection people felt with our story um
there was it was double-edged I would
say for on one hand the the love and
support that we got from people around
the world really was a Saving Grace it
really did make me feel far less lonely
in a very lonely time when I was
quarantining away from my friends and um
and at the same time there was this this
expectation that that their their love
bought a ticket to our lives and and I
wasn't willing to share everything
because some things were too sacred to
share and also rivs is a very very
private person and I KN even though he
was unconscious I knew he wouldn't want
me to be taking pictures and sharing
them online I never once took shared a
picture of him sick um I knew that when
he and if if he woke up he could tell
the story how he wanted to and that's
why I chose to tell it only from my
emotional self I didn't really give many
medical updates I mostly gave
emotionally updates because that felt
that felt respectful right and the
writing that you share on
Instagram predates rivs illness I mean
this is something you've been doing for
a long time and you know there's lots of
people out there who fell in love with
you simply for your way with words uh so
the book in many ways is just an
extrapolation of that Talent it was only
a matter of time before you wrote a book
whatever it was going to be about I was
already writing one but yeah yeah and
and and there's a you know there's a a a
Zen Coen like sort of flare to some of
your posts but they're always very sort
of layered and deep and thoughtful and
honest um but I'm wondering you know I
think there's this before rivs got sick
MH there's this sort of perception of of
an idealized life right he's got this
extraordinary physique he's super
handsome he's just an athletic machine
you're very beautiful you have these
beautiful daughters and the projection
is one of maybe not Perfection but an
aspirational life yeah and then suddenly
you know that crashes into a wall um and
you're faced with you know I don't know
if this is anything you even think about
but I'm just wondering you know as
somebody as an outsider looking in like
wow people are are projecting onto you a
version of your life that isn't reality
yeah then do you feel a responsibility
to disabuse people of that or to try to
communicate with people in a way that
still is providing them with
something um like teachable moments or
or something aspirational out of what
you are enduring in real time yeah well
the truth is the the couple years before
rivs got sick were probably some of the
hardest years of for us personally and
in our marriage he was injured in the
Houston Marathon he so he couldn't run
and when rivs can't run he gets very
dark yeah and and as I mean we're just a
normal married couple we got married
when I was 22 years old and he was 23 we
were just babies and so we had to learn
to grow up together and we did not do it
perfectly and I think people have this
idea that we've figured it out because
he's able to he was able to you know
reach his goal of being a career athlete
and I was able to reach my goal of being
a a writer but it did not come without
many struggles and many fights and many
resentments that we still work through
now um and so to hear people say that
you know we we seem like we're the ideal
couple or that we're couple goals we
hate we cringe when people say couple
goals only because we're not we're
definitely not like we've but what we do
well is we encourage each other's
Independence and we've always done that
and I think that for us is really
important because we are both very um
Lone Wolf independent people and I think
that's what brought us together in the
first place um but I never felt a sense
of Duty to the public to um to give off
any particular um I don't know like
image of who we were I just I'm sorry if
we gave off the image that we were
perfect cuz we're definitely not no I'm
not saying it was intentional on your
part I think it's easy to sort of like
extrapolate absolutely yeah yeah and and
rivs especially really really doesn't
like that I I I'm very um passive like I
don't dwell on on things as much as he
does he is a definitely a deep deep
thinker as you know um and and he's
always thinking about what will people
Garner from this and um um and so we're
trying to now kind of um deconstruct the
notion that that we are this I don't
know perfect couple that have it figured
out on an almost sort of Mythic level
though when I think about rivs and you
know to your point of him being this
empath and being a very sensitive person
and even you write about this in the
book the fact that he you know he needs
to go out into nature and and engage
with Solitude so that he can ground
himself you know process like all the
energy that he takes on from from
everyone around him it's almost like
he's a he's a cleanser for others right
yeah and I can't help but think like in
this sort of
archetypal
way you know the the
illness the illness that
that that he got like is was this
because like he reached his Max in his
ability to kind of process you know
other people's toxicity and he was he
was doing it you know in a selfless way
for others yeah well he always talks
about it as a gift and a curse and
mostly a curse that his ability to
absorb other people's emotions because
to to the person that he's helping
obviously it's a gift but he doesn't
know how to metabolize that emotion
other than running and so when he
doesn't get to run again it just sits in
him and he always says I feel like I'm
rotting um and and I think that's really
really heavy for him and and then to be
partnered with someone like that you you
do need to understand their need to be
alone for hours and hours at a time and
that was part of my learning experience
as a 22-year-old newly married to say
why does my husband want to be gone six
or 7 hours a day and it took me a long
time to realize that that he needs that
because he is like you said this
archetypal figure that he is quite
literally healing himself and others and
when he got sick
I I felt this acute just realization
that the sickness was not purely
pathological there was an element of um
the the stress and the emotion that he
had been absorbing was was making him
sick and his inability to run was
causing that and I I don't know I'm not
saying with certitude that you know
stress made gave him cancer but I think
there was a component to that yeah and
so a lot of times when he was in the
coma I would try to tell him as best I
could to just let it go just to release
what he could because it wasn't his to
bear and um I think that was all part of
his healing yeah the healing being
multifaceted on the one hand um you know
what is the opportunity for him right
perhaps there are other ways for him to
process all of this outside of running
and there's an opportunity for him to
explore
some other modalities um there's an
opportunity for him to figure out how to
have some healthy boundaries so he's not
you know in this osmosis where he's just
you know like a sponge for everybody
else's [__] you know I think there's
something interesting there you know
yeah and that that's probably really
uncomfortable for him I would think cuz
like running is you know well especially
now that he can't he can't do yeah he
can't so he's he's he's now he can't run
away from this and he has to figure out
other ways yeah and that's I mean he
still does go out for you know a couple
hours a day but it's not the same he
can't there's not that catharsis of just
endless like just rigorous smiles and
glycogen depletion and all of that so
he's yeah we're both figuring out these
new selves that we find ourselves in um
the post illness um so and we're also
getting to know each other in that way
you know we're both very different
people now so yeah who is he without
being a professional run
and yeah yeah you have to you have to
redefine what those roles look like and
how you're interacting with each other
and learning how to just be which for
both of us is very
hard you know just to be and I think
that I'm we're both he especially and
and in reading your book you and rivs
are quite similar in in a lot of ways in
in self-discipline self-determination
extremism um and and he has a hard time
not pushing the limits and not just
having a goal and reaching the goal and
then what's the next goal and so we're
realizing that one of the hardest parts
of being alive is to just be and that
doesn't mean being stagnant and just
sitting around and doing nothing but
feeling
fulfilled being and and I that's that's
where we're what I'm trying to do right
now is this book didn't make me happier
you know and and I think in some some
part of my mind I thought that reaching
this goal would make me happier and and
realizing that accomplishments don't do
much but stroke our egos you know and
then we're left with that kind of not
crash but just realizing okay I'm still
me I'm still a mom I'm still you know
I'm still Steph with all of my problems
and issues even though I accomplished
this goal and so my next goal is just be
so Hard One to be goess to be goalless
yeah and terrifying it is and for rivs
too and and we're both in the same place
where we're just really trying to just
be it's hard yeah I had uh my friend
light Watkins on the podcast the other
day he's a meditation teacher and he
said something along the lines of you
know the happiness that you will
experience when you Summit Everest is
the happiness that you brought to the
summit right it's not going to change
right like that's between you and you
outside of any kind of
externalities um and that's that is the
Mount Everest decline right yeah
absolutely the whole thing yeah how is
uh I mean how is his health now how is
he doing he's good yeah I mean other
than the lung damage which is what more
or less irreparable I mean I think they
can have so see small improvements but
he basically has COPD from the tumor
damage um but he's doing what he can and
and he's healthy he's cancer free so
that's all we can ask for you know
yeah I want to uh go back and explore
your background a little bit and your
kind of relationship with religion and
spirituality um growing up in a Mormon
household and and being this sort of
rebellious youth like walk me through
the Salient aspects of of that yeah so I
was raised in the LDS religion um my mom
had converted when she was 14 years old
and met and married my dad who was not
Mormon which in itself is kind of an
anomaly as if you know Mormons you know
that you're you're taught to Mor to
marry other Mormons but so I was already
raised in a household that wasn't 100%
culturally Mormon or or even genetically
Mormon you know um and still I had this
firm belief in in the faith um and when
my father got sick I truly believe that
my faith could heal him that if I prayed
enough and that if I was obedient enough
that he would be healed because that's
what I was taught both like really
overtly actually if you have a perfect
Faith Miracles will be granted and so
when that didn't happen when my father
finally passed away a few days after my
14th birthday I completely dispelled any
notion of not only religion but of
spirituality and inspiration and any
notion of Hope um because I felt so
deeply betrayed by those Notions um and
and so if God and Faith weren't real
then nothing was and so I could do
whatever I want and and and so I I drank
I think I was 4 days after my 14th
birthday and I got drunk at a house
party and I cried I spent the night
crying under a dining room table it was
my big brother brought me home um and
and I feel like that was it and I didn't
ever realize that I was drinking because
I was grieving I really thought I was
just making a normal teenage decision um
it really took me maybe five or six
years to realize that the path I was on
the destructive path I was on maybe was
a result of my father's death and that's
how how disconnected I was from myself
right you're unconsciously reacting and
responding to this trauma without really
understanding why you're doing what
you're doing and thinking it's for other
this is the this is the point this lives
within you it's an entity until you heal
it yep y absolutely and so I I I went
down I kept I I also feel as though and
again this is something I read in your
book which I appreciated that there was
something bigger than myself always
looking out for me and even though I
didn't believe in that thing I could
have should have been dead or in jail or
you know so many things should have
happened to me that didn't and I feel
like there was always something stopping
me from going over the pushing the limit
just that last little bit um and and now
I wonder if that was my dad which was
something I would have never ever even
entertained that thought um up until
ribs got sick yeah um and I don't know I
still don't know but I wonder was there
a
conscious um impulse to to like numb the
pain or was this just I'm partying like
everyone else and or was there a a
sensibility of of searching for some
kind of answers that would replace that
fall from grace that you had with
Mormonism I I think it was this feedback
loop where I I drank because I wanted to
cuz I was angry and I wanted to feel and
it was the only when I was drunk was the
only time I allowed myself to cry and it
was the only time that I kind of allowed
myself to feel anything at all and so I
was doing it but then I was feeling
guilty because I was raised Mormon and
raised to believe that you know any kind
of drinking or any kind of partying was
a sin and then that made me feel guilty
so then I would drink more because I
felt guilty and so I was just in this
just downward spiral and obviously none
of it worked yeah and when you were able
to emote when you were under the
influence like I'm curious about what
the relationship in your household
growing up as a kid was with kind of
sharing your emotions openly I mean how
is that yeah we didn't do that not a lot
of that right we didn't really do that I
I mean I shocking yeah I mean and I
talked to my mom about it now who uh you
know I portray her in this book as this
Bri British stoic which she she was she
was
very very stoic and and beautifully so I
think that her strength and her um lack
of showing emotion actually just carried
us through um and then it was our
responsibility later to learn how to
grieve and um and I feel like for me
that was the perfect way to do it I know
that people could say yeah you weren't
able to show your emotions it wasn't
that we weren't able to it's just we
didn't know how and when your father
passed away how was that explained to
you by your mother and and what is the
emotional residue of that experience she
we didn't ever talk we didn't talk about
it we didn't talk about it was you know
I came home he had passed away while I
was out at
Walmart um and you know she looked at me
said dad died we were expecting it it
wasn't a shock and and that was kind of
that was that right you know there was
no there was really and and I think now
and this is one of the wonderful parts
of writing this book um is I realized
why she did that and because talking to
your children about grief is an
impossible task and one that I was
having to confront and it wasn't until I
had to confront it for myself that I
realized that she did it perfectly
because there's no way to do it you're
you're grieving and you're trying to
tenure the pain of your own children
it's impossible and you do whatever you
do and that's the right way to do it
right it's another example of the
universe lining up to you know infer an
opportunity out of this Dad long cancer
Riv lung cancer um this is how my mom
dealt with it and communicated to me
when I was a kid now I'm in that
position and I have this very difficult
choice and I now appreciate more deeply
how difficult it was for my mother so I
can forgive her have more empathy for
her maybe make different choices um but
heal whatever wounding the existed over
the way in which she parented you and
communicated with you yeah absolutely
and that I didn't actually realize the
depth of that healing until I was
writing the book and and a lot of times
writing is how I make sense of the world
and it wasn't until I was writing all
that she did for me and the parallels
between our lives at really around the
same age um when my dad was six she was
quite young too and and it was just kind
of this aha moment that oh my goodness I
am in my mother's position and I am
doing pretty much the same thing that
she did I'm not able to talk to my kids
very well about the possibility that
rivs might die because I don't know how
to say these words to them it's
impossible and I I did show more emotion
to my kids um but again I don't think I
did it perfectly I'm sure in 10 years
they're going to turn around and
criticize the way that I led them
through that tragedy and and I'm
expecting it it's rigged that way it
wouldn't matter whatever choice you made
they're going to have their issues with
it and they can talk to their therapist
about it write a book about you know
what I mean and be mad about how you
didn't do X Y or Z and that's the way it
should be right this is how the species
evolves um but it is again one of those
dualities like you want to be strong
make sure that your kids feel safe and
protected and that you know everything
is going to be okay but you also want to
have that open channel of communication
you want to be able to model um you know
vulnerability and and you know what it
what it looks like to go through
something hard imperfectly I think
that's an important lesson as well and
those two things are in tension with
each other and I think probably every
parent who's had to deal with some kind
of difficult issue and how to
communicate to their kids about it you
know butts up against that yeah yeah it
is it's an impossible task and a lot of
people actually one of the most asked
questions I get is what advice do you
give to a parent going through something
similar and I don't have any I I wish I
had advice I wish I could write out a
formula for the perfect way to lead a
child through tragedy but there isn't
one and and also each child is so
different each of my children have dealt
with ribs illness so differently and
it's not one siiz fits all you know and
and so it's you just do your best and
and and they'll they'll be [__] up no
matter what I'm I know right um but I
think that the other yes like it's
important to not just give blanketed
advice for this kind of thing but one
thing that you make clear in the book is
you had to overcome like you you were
sort of operating under like you know
like I'm protecting them like they don't
need to know the details and then you
know the the the just the overwhelm of
all of it leads you to a certain kind of
breakdown and you end up opening up to
your kids uh you know somewhat in a
vulnerable way and that was received
well like it was received with empathy
and I think what I take from that is
when in doubt like don't underestimate
your children's ability to appreciate
the humanness and I think that they will
end up respecting you more if you're
transparent with them if you're hiding
something because and even if you're
doing it for the right reasons like you
want to protect them that's what leads
to you know distrust and all kinds of
other stuff and that doesn't mean that
you're just you know unfiltered in all
of it you have to be responsible but I
think there's a lot of wisdom and
understanding even if they're young and
obviously what age they are is important
um that kids are resilient and um maybe
they can't handle everything but they
can probably handle more than you might
suspect yeah and and I guess that that's
a good thing to point out was I was
keeping from them some of the the
details of what was happening and the
severity of those relief details that
rivs could probably die and that's what
I was keeping from them but I was not
holding back with my emotion with
especially with Harper you're you're
referencing my me breaking down in
Harper's arms she was 10 at the time and
she pulled me in and she comforted me
and I hope that that was a beautiful
moment for her probably really tragic
and sad but also just realizing that my
mom is human cuz growing up my mom never
felt completely human she was just this
C like incredibly strong powerful like
just unmovable person and and I tried to
emulate that it's hard to connect with
someone like that yeah and and I think
that I hope that Harper can learn from
me um sadness it's okay to be sad that's
something I never knew was it's okay to
be sad um and and I'm trying to model
for my children that sadness isn't a
negative emotion I mean it's an
appropriate response to a very difficult
situation and and that we can feel like
you know the premise of this book
everything all at once we can feel
sadness and fear and love and joy all in
the same moment we don't have to choose
and and that was that was huge for me to
learn it's also an expansive definition
of strength we think of strength in a
very in very narrow terms like to be
strong is to be tacern and to like keep
your [__] together or whatever but I
think it's a different kind of strength
to allow yourself to experience
difficult emotions and to do it with
people you care about because you have
to trust them and it takes a certain
strength to do that even if they're your
your children yeah absolutely yeah and
and Harper For Better or Worse is also
an empath she is rivs Incarnate she is I
see it in her and I think that's also
why I felt comfortable breaking down in
her arms because it was almost as though
she was the wiser one in that moment I
felt like she she could feel the the
vastness of all of it and she could take
it and
as long as the only caveat I would add
to that as long as she doesn't feel she
isn't made to feel that it's her
responsib responsibility absolutely yep
and that's kind of how I ended that
chapter was hoping that they knew that
my sadness wasn't something that they
would ever have to carry because someone
else's sadness you can't carry it you
can't take it upon yourself and you can
just Comfort them in those times yeah um
back to the sex drugs and rock and roll
yeah uh
so I I you know I love stories like this
where oh yeah let's get into it um
despite your adventures you know with
errant boyfriends and vans and you know
trolling around the valley in Los
Angeles Etc I never I never got the
sense that you really had a problem with
drugs and alcohol I felt like you're
being you're in you're in weird
codependent relationships with
boyfriends who had problems and so
you're going to meetings because that's
what they need yeah yeah I mean well but
then the problem is that because I don't
I don't have well this is going to sound
weird with how many tattoos I have but I
actually don't have an addictive
personality like ribs and I are
different in that rivs is Extreme and
it's all or nothing I am actually quite
moderate in a lot of ways that I am able
to but you like the extreme dudes I do
and obviously your addic this is the
addiction yeah and the problem is is
that I can do things moderately and they
can't and so a lot of the guilt of my
adolescence was I'm leading all of these
people away from sobriety cuz I I did it
on a few occasions just in my book right
you're the temptress I'm the temptress
and I don't mean to be I just I like to
have a good time and I could do it
within parameters you know yeah but what
is it you think inside of you that leads
you to be attracted to these extreme
personalities yeah good question I I
don't know I'll get back to you on that
but I um I think that there's something
extreme about me I mean obviously I'm
covered in tattoos and somehow I am able
to do moderation or or something is
keeping me from going over the edge and
I still haven't figured that out that's
still what I'm trying to figure out is
why am I not um going over the edge and
so I'm still figuring all of this out
it's it's quite new it's still new to me
yeah well you got lucky in picking an
extreme dude in the form of rivs because
typically like they don't come in such a
healthy package right he's extremely
healthy that's the
extremism yeah but I mean he has a
tendency toward I know he spoke with you
about this the addiction of the opiates
um he is he and he's sober now and and
that's um that's huge for him and for me
too um because it kind of it helps me to
I feel like it's going to be a long path
but I I feel like I'll get there
interesting yeah I think it's Tangled Up
In This ongoing um Reckoning with
spirituality yeah at the core of of your
searching um and in thinking about the
inflection points along that timeline uh
there's another interesting one which is
when you decide to go to BYU in Hawaii
and you have this encounter with this
bishop and you make this choice to be
kind of more honest than perhaps that
guy was used to getting a surprising
response from him yeah yeah I so part of
um being admitted to BYU Hawaii which is
a Mormon obviously institution is you
need to um go through a an
ecclesiastical endorsement and so
basically there's a checklist that they
ask you do you abstain from drugs sex
alcohol it's like no no no and and I
knew I was going to quote unquote fail
right and and when he when I told him
everything I divulged everything and
really at the time it did feel like a
[__] you to to God it felt like you know
everyone else is just saying yes to pass
the test and they're checking boxes
exactly and you can easily drink coffee
no no no why never and so that I also
added that into my story him saying you
know those things don't really matter
you're a good person and I added that in
that true story in because I kind of you
know dog on Mormonism a bit in in my
book but I also wanted to show that
there's good people there there's good
people everywhere and just because that
religion didn't resonate with me it
doesn't mean that it's all full of
self-righteous bigots you know there are
good people in those religions so and he
gave you kind of a surprisingly
capacious response that allowed you to
reframe yeah that resentment exactly
yeah yeah but didn't stop me from
partying at
by question is why did I it's almost
like I why did I choose a Mormon
college right you know I it's almost
like already rejected that so how that
was a question that I had like how did
you end up there yeah and I think the
answer is and and maybe going back to
why am I I I think that I want so badly
to
be so I don't know I wanted so badly to
be good and I just didn't know how to do
it and I didn't know what good meant and
all I knew was good was what was taught
to me and my religion which which is
abstinence and obviously it's so much
more than just that and that's something
I'm still still learning yeah yeah and
that but it's a search for it's not
maybe not necessarily a search for
goodness but a search for somebody to
tell you that you're good right or to
make you feel okay with who you are and
that's exactly what that Bishop did y
exactly yeah yeah it's it is fascinating
that you ended up going there allh
um and so what does that look like now I
mean everything all at once this is a
you know non-dogmatic
expansive uh you know concept of of
spiritual energy and the way that the
Universe works yeah that you can't quite
put a name on it you don't attempt to do
that uh it seems that the overarching
energy here is is love but like how do
you define your relationship with the
Unseen yeah
it's it's ongoing it's evolving it's
different from even when I wrote the
book um when I wrote the book I felt
very
certain about what I had felt and seen
and now as I get farther away from that
experience I question more and more I'm
I'm a cynic so I will question no matter
what but I when I reread the book I
realized that it was very true to me um
the the spirituality of of it all and I
can't deny as much as I want to deny
that there was a strong spiritual
component to everything that happened um
yeah it it was when I walked into ri's
room when he was
sedated I felt more connected to the
universe than I ever had in my entire
life and and a moment a moments that
should have been terrifying and tragic
and sad were some of the most
love-filled moments I'd ever experienced
in my life s sitting next to a my
sedated husband on two different life
support machines and the only way I was
able to explain that well try to explain
that is that it was this ex this
otherworldly love that was just in the
room and it was it was palpable and you
walk in there and and I even talked to
the nurses and the doctors and you know
the therapists that were in the room and
they agree there was something
transcendental happening in that room
and I couldn't deny it and they can't
deny it even the doctors were like there
was some miracle and Magic going on in
this room and and I can't explain it and
I don't know what it was um I like to
believe it was part my dad that was
there I love to believe that um some
form of god
goddess but it was love no matter what
you call it it was love the doctors
recounting their their version of that
story being unique to ribs because
they're in that scenario every single
day with different people right yeah so
what is it about ribs that helped
co-create that type of shared experience
do you think well interestingly what
they said was it wasn't necessarily him
but it was it was the bond between us
right that was felt transformative which
shocked me um one of his first nurses
wrote me a letter about how she had
never met him awake she had never seen
us interact but somehow the like the
palpable love that she could
feel changed her whole idea of love and
I wasn't trying to do anything and he
was asleep but I think it was it was a
beautiful connection that not only
between me and him but the love that I
was bringing from the world and almost
as though I was a conduit and and kind
of transferring that love into him and
it was it was incredible and it was
crazy it felt like I felt like a lot of
times I would leave that hospital room
and I felt like nauseous as though I I
was the empath all of a sudden like I
was absorbing and transferring which is
something I had never ever experienced
before but I'd heard ribs talk about it
a bunch and it's almost like we switched
roles and I was able to do for him what
he had been doing for other people right
while you're also for the first time
shouldering responsibility for your own
growth and person
is going take it all powerful sudden oh
[__] like I have to do this for myself
and then I have to go home and figure
out how to do it with these kids in
private while I'm suffering and grieving
all at the same time and then on top of
that the doctors or it was one doctor I
think who said to you listen you know a
huge part of whether or not he's going
to make it is up to you you're a part of
this healing process like what are you
you bringing to this equation which
speaks to exactly what you just shared
like are you contributing to his
Improvement or are you you know sucking
life out from underneath him because
you're dealing with too much already and
you're upset because he's not going to
fix you anymore right exactly and that's
well that's what I found is every day
that I went in there it was I think 101
days and he was sedated for 50 of those
days and I went in every I didn't miss a
single day and every day that I went in
I felt more and more alive and connected
to myself in a time where I should have
been falling apart and part of me was
but recognizing that the fullness of me
is falling apart that's okay it's okay
to feel strong and completely weak at
the same time it's okay to feel anger
and and gratitude at the same time and
and the more that I accepted the really
the monism not even Duality like how
complimentary these feelings were not
contradictory and the more I allowed
those complimentary emotions the more
powerful I felt and and as I get F
farther away from that I I I don't feel
it as much you know now and I think that
a lot of times we are we have the choice
to become our best selves in the worst
times and somehow I became my best self
in the worst time of my life I don't
know how again I wish I had a guide book
but it was just recognizing the power
that had always been inside of meh and
it wasn't in rivs you know and it and
realizing that I was more powerful not
necessarily on my own but in this moment
where I didn't depend on him yeah you
had a capacity that was latent within
you and pain and challenge is The
Crucible for connecting with that and
and and sort of bringing it forth into
the world so it was that's the
opportunity right the interesting thing
is if you if you coign to the idea that
all of us have capacity and potential
that we're walking around with that
we're just not aware of or yeah uh we
haven't really you know brought forth in
our own lives um do we really need to be
in that kind of a tragic event or to
suffer yeah extreme pain in order to
manifest it yeah it's a choice yeah it
just rarely happens short of you know
basically being boxed into a corner in
that kind of a way yeah well similarly
ribs and I are for lack of a better word
happier together than we've ever been
and people are like how are you so happy
I'm like uh just make him almost die and
then you'll you know what I mean you'll
go through together this recognition of
how much you love each other and how
important you are to each other and
things that we take for granted that are
sometimes times only shown to us in the
depths of Despair sadly how do you
access that feeling of gratitude and
awareness when you're not in the depths
and I'm struggling with that now even
please tell me how to do that yeah right
oh you don't know oh cuz I I'm now even
I want to maintain the lessons I learned
be present there's no better moment than
this moment right now and all the love
you ever need is inside of you all of
these truths I know them but it's harder
to feel them when life is good right and
imagine your rivs where your whole life
is oriented around connecting with
suffering as a vehicle for growth and
truth and self- understanding and
appreciation and suddenly that preferred
voluntary version of suffering is
replaced with a different type of
challenge overcoming this illness and
then on the heels of that Stillness the
suffering is not being able to uh engage
with your chosen version of suffering
it's a passive suffering and I'm sure
that is much more uncomfortable for him
it would be for me yeah yeah yeah well
and also there's I think there's a
physiological component to the
metabolizing energy that alone I mean he
literally was using the energy that he
absorbed from other people to metabolize
his run transmute it yeah exactly and
now that he can't do that it's he has a
hard time being around people
that's the truth because he ABS well he
absorbs what he can't
metabolize is he actively searching for
alternative ways of doing that yeah yep
I think he's he's yeah figuring it out
we yeah but it's yeah it's a it's a
journey for sure
yeah I want to talk about the time
malleability stuff this sort of quantum
idea I mean obviously if you're rivs and
you're in a coma you're going to have
and you come out of it you're going to
have a unique relationship with time
yeah um but time is a bendable concept
that is influenced by the extremity of
what you're experiencing time slows down
time speeds up Etc um but in this
Quantum sense this idea that like there
is no past and there is no future we're
on this sort of recursive Loop where
everything is happening all the time on
some on in some Dimension um is is a
fascinating one uh I I'm I'm curious as
to whether that was initially prompted
by your psychedelic
experiences and it's something that I'm
dealing with right now and in a
different way I've got a family member
who's suffering from dementia and to
just observe that person you know their
their their relationship with time is
complet you know like they could be one
minute they're living 10 years ago and
then they're and you know so that's got
to be scary but also you know it's
bizarre because then you have to visit
that timeline and you know memory is an
anchor for time right and our
relationship to memory is is a way of
time traveling I guess on some level so
walk me through this whole concept that
is really the whisper in the background
on every page of this book yeah well and
that's even why I wrote the memories
that tethered me to myself throughout my
life are written in present tense
because what I learned and what I'm
learning is that
memory our memory is the the cursor to
things that are always happening these
memories are actually ever present and
and we can access them and go back to
that time in a in a moment well they're
they're consciously or unconsciously
impacting every decision that we make so
they do live in the present they do
absolutely and um I mean the most the
like the the starkest example of this
was when rivs was at the end of his life
and I went in there to say goodbye is
what they told me to do and I rested my
head on his chest and in a moment we
were dancing together and we were living
that moment together in the present and
nobody could tell me that didn't happen
that I was not metaphysically there cuz
I was my body was here but I was there
with him and we were dancing together
and that
that memory I feel Drew us back together
into this world and and called him back
to this life and I think that example
was why I wanted to
weave the malleability of time into into
my whole book um because I realized that
it was memory that was saving me over
and over again mostly the memory of love
and and that's what I feel kept me me my
whole life from going over the edge
these these everpresent
moments of presence um that I was called
back to and um and on the other hand
rivs he lived lifetimes in his coma he
was I mean he has some incredible
stories about where he was and where he
went and how many different families he
had and and who's to say that those
weren't real that those weren't really
occurring lives you know I'm not I would
never say he says some of those memories
of when he was in the coma feel more
real than this life memory you know wow
so I'm really really interested in the
quantum aspect that I don't I wish I
understood on a physics level yeah um
but I all I know is my experience with
with time and um yeah so what do we take
from that how are we supposed to
interpret that or how is that meant to
from your perspective inform Our Lives I
mean really it's that love is woven into
every aspect of our lives in in the form
of
memory um and that in the most tragic
Moments Love or the memory of Love is
still there and I like to think of my
father whether he exists in a spiritual
realm or just in a memory I think that
the memory of his love is the same as
thing that he lives in some spirit world
and that that love is entwined in in
every aspect of my life and um and it's
in all of our lives and if what one of
the most pivotal moments of of my um
life today was recognizing how that love
had been in in everything absolutely
everything when I was drunk crying under
a table when I was hitchhiking through
Guatemala when I was you you know
everything that I did love was there I
just I just didn't recognize it in
myself so I couldn't recognize it in
other people how do we tap into that do
we have to you know doyin like can we
can I how do I I want I want some of
that juice stuff have you ever done
psychedelics I haven't okay and I know
okay so that's probably touchy cuz
psychelic it comes up all the time on
the podcast we talk about it a lot cuz
you've had Gabor mate here right so had
lots of people you know you know
explored this extensively and I won't
bore the listeners with my perspective
on it I you know only to say that
because I'm sober I have trepidation
around it but I also can't dismiss or
deny the efficacious you know benefits
that I've seen many people have and the
interesting science that's coming out
about yeah how it's helpful for people
with depression and PTSD um but on a
purely you know kind of spiritual plane
I'm interested in the epip
and the truths that then seemed to
persist well beyond that experience and
in your case clearly you know have
informed your entire worldview yeah well
I I really do credit psychedelics with
my ability to handle rib's illness the
way I did um it was only six months
before he got sick that I did my hero
mushroom journey and that's what cracked
me open to the possibility of
spirituality and think had I not had
that experience I might not have been
open to even the idea that rivs existed
somewhere other than in his body maybe I
wouldn't be open to the fact that I
could conduct love into him through some
spiritual Cosmic Channel and I really
think had I not had that mushroom
experience I wouldn't have been able to
do the things that I did with and for
him um but that being said I I know some
people who are kind of militant about PS
or about psychedelics and think it's the
only way I think it's the quickest way
to get there but I do believe there are
other channels um my sister-in-law is a
Quantum healer and she does like the
holotropic breathing um meditation but
of course that takes a lot more time and
mental energy than just drinking a tea
and going right there you know yeah yeah
yeah holotropic breathing I'll bring you
there pretty quick I've never done it
I'm I'm terrified I don't we do these
Retreats and Julie my wife takes people
through holotropic breathing sizes and
and and in our past Retreat our most
recent one she took everyone through it
like on day one like let's just cut
through the [__] right now and like
people are having insane experiences and
everyone would go around the room and
share afterwards and like I was an eagle
and I was flying you know what's really
cool and what I love about yeah my mom
is you know she's Mormon still and she's
on this whole journey where she went to
Thailand she she's mostly vegan she did
a vegan cleanse M and did a holotropic
breathing experience and you know coming
from a really like Puritan religion
that's not accepted really this you know
outside spirituality but she did it and
she said she saw Jesus and Buddha and
they were both equally important I'm
like there you go and and for her to the
expansive just I love I love that you
know that that's what she saw and they
were both equally important so I do
think that Sil Ivan is wonderful for me
it worked I haven't done another hero
trip since
what I needed at the time does that mean
hero TR well you take like [__] like
five G like a massive dose where you
complete disillusion of ego like I
didn't know who I was where I was um but
I needed to do that because I was so
dissociated from myself so I needed
something to and this was only you know
four years ago um I needed something to
crack me open and to show me I had been
compartmentalizing my grief i' had been
compartmentalizing my feeling feelings
um I wasn't fully healed you never
really are it's okay to feel everything
all at once I needed that
shaking um but I don't need that now I
was I was shook you know rib's illness
cracked me even wider open I don't need
it right now and I think it's
recognizing when and if you need that
rewiring or that you know restructuring
of your brain and your thought patterns
and I'm recognizing that I'm still on
I'm still on the trip you know I mean
I'm I'm still going and um I know they
recommend doing it something like every
six months but I cannot fathom they yeah
who is that the mushroom people this my
brain's like can I do it every day well
you can micro do but that doesn't do it
for me that didn't ever do it for me um
although it did help me get out of
depression once micro doing but anyways
I don't think it's a blanket uh I think
some people use it as as the Beall end
all uh answer I don't think anything is
you know I think you got to see the way
I I think about it is it's a portal into
a state of consciousness that would
otherwise be difficult to access not
impossible yeah um and for some people
that's just enough to shift them and get
them interested in in a different way of
navigating the world that otherwise they
would never have you know been open to I
guess and I got there when ribs was sick
every day without the need for any
substance I I got there every time I was
in his room felt like that kind of
transcendental experience but like we've
been saying do you have to go there do
you have to suffer to feel it may maybe
you do maybe you do it is a very Heroes
Journey kind of architecture to this
story I'm sure when you're in the middle
of it like anybody who's challenged by
life you're thinking why is this
happening to me I finally you know had
this life and I worked so hard and I did
all these things and suffered and
explored and now I'm happy and then all
of this is happening why and what and
but when you look in the rearview mirror
it's like everything's lining up
perfectly for this experience obviously
you're choosing events and moments and
iming them with meaning um to you know
to create a narrative right which is not
any more real than some other if you had
chosen a whole bunch of other events to
view them with meaning so there a lot of
human imposed Ingenuity on top of it but
when I look at you know first of all
your dad wasn't the first person in your
life to suffer from cancer you had you
had a brother like you had you you met
that at how old were you 13 or something
like that you were super young three I
was six so that was your F universe is
knocking hey here's a little thing how
you going to deal with this oh wasn't
enough here well let's throw your dad
into the mix and see what happens here I
guess uh you know she's got have some
more adventures and you know and then
okay well I'm going to drop an anvil on
on this person's head in the form of you
know rivs and a rare form of lung cancer
um and also six months prior to that you
go off and do this siloc cyan thing
which is sort of seeding you or
preparing you to have a different
experience this time uh with a with a a
a new lens that would allow you to
navigate it with an expanded perception
of meaning I'm man I I'm really we I
don't like saying that I see but it is I
know what you're saying but I do univers
didn't decide to do all of these things
for you I understand that but can you
find meaning in them and extract that
meaning to you know to kind of you know
to grow and evolve I guess well and more
than that how could I look back and not
see how it was a little eerily not
predestined but everything like you said
l up so
perfectly I can't I hate it but I can't
deny that it did feel
very uh meant to be in some you're
you're like Luke Skywalker in your own
movie you you know what I I I don't ask
why did these bad things happen to me
because far worse things happen to
people and I'm very aware of that and I
really am and I I don't think I've had
some tragedy filled I've had a very
beautiful life um I chose to tell the
tragedy side of my life but I've had a
pretty good life well first of all
you're you're you're being careful to
not portray yourself or be perceived in
any way as a victim right and also that
you're not the main character in some
Grand you know architecture of the
universe conspiring just for you right
like you're just a person living your
life things happen yeah I never asked
why did these bad things happen to me I
I really never have but I ask why why
did all these good things happen around
these bad things why did I get so much
guidance and love and assistance
throughout my life when so many people
are left alone and and I think that's
where that's the why that I ask it's
almost like a survivor's guilt like why
was I so lucky to have so much love in
my life when I know a lot of people
don't have that and and so in some way
that's why I wrote the book as this
tribute to love itself because I've had
so much of it and and wanting to honor
that is the thing that kept me alive my
whole life um and but that is the why
that I ask why why me why why am I so
lucky to have that help yeah yeah you
were talking about goals earlier and and
certainly you know you had a goal of
writing a book and having people enjoy
it I'm sure youve set other goals in
your life but at the same time you don't
strike me as like a plotter and a
planner you you strike me as somebody
who is living your life based on gut
instinct and you're making spontaneous
decisions and you're not really thinking
that far ahead right and
and
and life has worked out um which maybe
mystifies you because you didn't plan it
or you're not thinking ahead you're just
this is what my heart is telling me I'm
going to jump and go here which I think
is a really beautiful way to live I know
some other people that live that way
they're just like I never worry about as
long as I'm connected to my heart and it
feels right to me I do it and I have
faith and trust and I can make a leap
yeah um but that requires like a level
of trust in your own instincts to guide
you that's spoton ribs and I always joke
that uh he that I'm I'm just the
ultimate coaster and I always have been
I've just I've just allowed life to
happen you know and I allow it to happen
and I'm just there for the ride and bad
things have happened along the way but
somehow it's always worked out for me
but there's and then there's someone
like rivs that plans every moment of
every day and knows what five years from
now is going to look like and I don't
even think about to today I don't know
what I'm going to do this afterno when
you're not thinking ahead like that and
things go well and you're surrounded by
love it's impossible to not believe that
on some level you're being guided and
taken care of but you also can't
prescribe that to other people cuz think
it's also could be dangerous to live
that way what's interesting is that it
worked out given your level of
disconnection from self because I would
I would say to somebody who operates
that way make sure you're really
connected with who you are otherwise
that gut instinct is just some weird
memory that you're being prompted by and
you don't know why and that can all go
terribly yeah wrong and often it does
yeah and that's why I do attribute some
of my earlier life
survival really to something I can't
explain because I wasn't connected to
myself and I was extremely Reckless and
and still it all worked out as a
22-year-old I chose to marry rivs who I
was partying at the time and I was
Reckless and wild and he was just off
his mission like a really sweet Mormon
boy and
somehow he finds me go Mission Brazil
yeah yeah did he have a beard at 22 no
you're not allow I can't even imagine
what he looked like you can't he was
really well he handsome but he he has
like a really good jawline but but again
I like why how how did that and what was
it about him again well what about him I
mean what wasn't it about but I mean
what was it about me I feel like we just
knew and I I as I write in my book when
I saw him it was almost like another one
of those memories like I know you it
doesn't make sense but I know you
somehow and um kind of like how you said
in your book that you said you were
going to marry your wife wife right that
day it's and I'd never felt that way
before I didn't even think I was going
to get married I thought I was just
going to Coast my whole life and be a
beach bum and and then I he walked into
class and it was just oh my gosh there
you are you know and that's some past
life [__] yeah exactly and that's or
just this cyclical nature of time and
the bleeding of past and future together
into an interesting present present for
now and and again like yeah that ability
of time it's we this isn't my friend
Vanessa in flag step says this isn't
your first rodeo stuff you know the
things the way that life is lined up for
you it's not your first time you dove
into this knowing exactly what you were
going to do and who you were going to
meet and I when she used to say that I
was like oh my gosh that's such [__]
you know and now I'm seeing it unfold
and it's truer every day so Wow have you
seen the movie arrival yeah no no I
don't think so oh this is your homework
stuff I'm signing this movie to you
denille it's a science fiction movie
Aliens come um but it's really about our
relationship with and our perception of
time that's that's really what the movie
is about and I think it's going to blow
your mind okay right so you're going
watch that that's what I'll do tonight
now I have a plan for the first time of
my life in addition to the quantum time
past present stuff and the the you know
the the DU themes there's
also I guess this is sort of a cousin to
to uh the non dualism aspects of the
story
but the story is also about what's what
lives in the between spaces you know the
Lial spaces between between um death and
life right between day and night between
religion and spirituality and and and
what lives in between anger and
happiness gratitude Etc um or the
mundane and the sacred yeah so how do
you think about that or how did you kind
of plant your flag in that murkiness
well that was a huge theme I wanted to
explore because I was raised to believe
in polarity in you know good and evil
and sin in obedience and that damaged me
so much as a child because I believe
that Perfection was the goal and and if
I wasn't perfect and living on that end
of the spectrum then I wasn't doing it
right and time and time again life
taught me
that EV life exists between the extremes
it it's not good or evil it's not right
and wrong it's everything all at once
really essentially and when I came to
accept that the best of Life exists in
the gray areas in the linal areas
then I was almost able to accept the
wholeness of myself because I am good
and bad and happy and angry and and I
always tried to give moral weight to my
emotions you know that gratitude was a
positive emotion and anger was a
negative emotion and and I truly
believed I had to choose between them
and then recognizing that there is no
moral weight to to emotion they just are
and they're necessary you know anger is
equally as necessary as gratitude in a
lot of cases
um that was shown to me by recognizing
how anger in my adolescence actually
fueled me and kept me alive when I think
had I not had anger kind of fueling me
forward I probably would have been far
more self-destructive and just kind
of desolate M um and and it wasn't until
rivs got sick that I learned to
appreciate that side of myself the
rageful angry side that that was really
essential to who I am um and then on the
spiritual side of that um rivs room was
the in between it was that that um it
wasn't life and it wasn't death and it
was a place that I still don't have
words for um but it was like a sanctuary
and I felt more alive in that space
between life and death and more
connected than I ever had in my in and I
think part of it is again going back to
time time didn't exist in that room
other than the monitors you know beeping
and kind of like bringing me back to to
the present there time kind of suspended
when I was with him and we could be in
Hawaii together and we could be caught
up in all these memories or past lives
whatever you want to call them um and
time ceased to exist and it was a really
sacred sacred space but again all of
this happened in between yeah I'm just
wondering how I can connect with
something some semblance of that into my
into my life you know it's just it's
it's a it's a peak
experience yeah and then it's
about the judgments that we attach to it
and thinking about your your Mormon
background a very
binary um structure right good bad evil
whatever um and then realizing to use
your words that actually there's a
fluidity to truth yeah and anger is not
necessarily bad or being sad it's a
story that we attach to certain emotions
but to your point these emotions are
neutral can we Embrace those aspects of
ourselves with the same you know level
of of compassion that we would embrace
the the aspirational emotions that we're
all seeking right meaning purpose
happiness
love Etc um and that's a challenge
because we have this this programming
you know we're supposed to be like this
and if we're not like that then there's
something wrong with us and that
judgment that we Levy upon ourselves
that punishment is the antithesis of the
compassion that we're striving to import
to others and yet are incapable of of
providing for ourselves yeah absolutely
and and what's interesting is it's it is
a Christian notion that
Duality you know light can ex exist
without Darkness but what I found was
it's not contradictory it's
complimentary and and that's a more
Eastern Buddhist way of looking at
things that it's not light versus dark
it's light and dark together and and
just like it is gratitude and anger
together they they compliment each other
and if they're complimentary why should
we shun one or exclude one um or favor
one over the other I don't know know why
do we do that why do we do
it I wish we I wish we didn't there
would be there's so much freedom on the
other side of that right yeah absolutely
and I felt it when rivs was sick that
love for my Brokenness that you know I'm
not feeling it as much anymore but
during that time I really I was like
that's why I am who I am today is cuz I
went through that and I was Reckless and
That Built Me to the person I am today
how could I regret those things if
they've taught me what I know now you
know I right in those broken pieces
those fractured splintered aspects of
ourselves ultimately you know on the
other side of healing become the most
beautiful pieces right what is that
Japanese art where when the China breaks
or you know they piece it back together
with beautiful glue and it becomes a
much more priz cherish possession as a
result of it because of its flaws yep
that was in my head a lot as as ribs was
sick that I this I just had this feeling
that something no matter the outcome
this was going to I was going to choose
to make this to make me stronger but I
knew it was a choice you know and I was
going to choose to make it make me
stronger um but it was It was obviously
a conscious and still is a conscious
choice that I have to make yeah is it
going to be a crucible for your growth
or are you going to allow it to destroy
you or Define you in some unhealthy way
or are you going to become a victim The
Narrative that you associate with it
becomes very powerful because it
reinforces meaning and that meaning can
be fluid just like everything else that
you speak about in the book right and
that's a choice just like anything else
and I think my favorite this is you know
on a similar vein like my favorite quote
out of the entire book um is when you
say human Frailty is the great Mason of
becoming to me that like says it all
yeah it's so explain explain you know
what's behind that for you well and
again it comes back to the the danger of
not wanting to say
that being broken makes us stronger
because it doesn't everyone but it is we
are given a choice in those dark moments
in the moments of
tragedy will you choose to make like
allow this to make you stronger or will
you choose to allow it to break you
beyond repair and I think that it's a
choice we can make 10 years down the
road um because I think that my father's
death The Narrative I told myself about
my response to grief in my adolescence
was that it broke me and I was Reckless
and I allowed it to break me and and now
I look back and I say wow that was
building me the whole time and even
though for over a decade I told myself
that I had had been broken really now I
reframe and say I was being built that
whole that whole time all of the
recklessness was building me to the
wisdom that I have today and and so it
really is that tragedy is is Amon and
we're building our we can choose to
build ourselves
stronger but it's again it's it's a
tricky and it's a tight RPP to walk um
and that choice has to me be made daily
it's a choice that we make and then it's
Everlasting you know yeah yeah uh
looming over this whole thing is this
non-dualistic idea of love it's all
about love love permeates everything
there's a little bit of like give me a
[__] break you know what I mean like
so you know it's like you're you're
exposing yourself as an easy target for
somebody who is maybe woke up on the
wrong side of the bed yep uh so help me
understand what you're really getting at
here because when I think about love I
mean I agree with you but I also think
of love showing up in different ways and
in different forms some love is
conditional some love is temporal
certain relationships aren't meant to
last forever they they come together a
beautiful thing happens and then and
then time passes and that Rel
relationship is complete um and then
there's the eternal love uh Julie my
wife likes to describe it as the son
that is shining the sun is not
Discerning if the Sun is emitting rays
of Light which are love it's not
Discerning where those rays are shining
it shines equally upon everyone without
judgment right that's a different type
of love I I suspect that's really what
you're getting at here but walk me
through this for for the the skeptical
naysay or you know brain that's
listening to right now me had I read
this book five years ago I would have
been like wow okay um really I mean the
universal love this ineffable love that
is everywhere and
unconditional and how that exists easy
for you to say beautiful with beautiful
kids you're like I know exactly but but
it is there if but I didn't see it I
didn't recognize it until just a few
years ago because I didn't have it
inside myself and I think that it's just
a reflection of what we have to give
ourselves and like I said earlier I was
searching for that love outside of
myself over and over again and I was
trying to fight it in drugs and alcohol
and men and countries and I it was an
insatiable thing because it didn't have
a receptacle inside of me and so the
love that I'm talking about is just a
reflection of what we can give ourselves
because it really is all around us all
the time you can see it in anyone
walking by the street if you choose to
see it but you're not going to see it if
you don't have that self- Lov inside of
you and again it's a daily decision that
I make to love myself and therefore feel
more love for Humanity and more love
from Humanity um and is there a
structure or a modality for practicing
that like what does that actually look
like you're asking me I have
no my my agent ask
here's my list here's how I do this I
never wrote an outline for my book it
was just going to happen but um that's
why it took you 10 years well yeah
exactly yeah it's true but I thank God
it did because it would it would have
been a different book you know five
years ago of course again that timing
that Cosmic timing thing but um I don't
I again yeah you're you're right people
are going to say yeah easy for you to
say you've had love throughout your life
but I also chose I'm choosing to see in
retrospect the love throughout my life
it's another choice that I'm making to
say I could also look back on my life
and say wow I had a really tragedy
filled life all I knew was hospitals
when I was a little kid my dad died when
I was 14 20 years later the love of my
life almost dies I could choose that
narrative I could tell that but I'm
choosing to see the love woven in and
out of all of those stories and and it's
a choice I make and it it is easy for me
to say but it's also not I could tell a
very different story um and and I'm
choosing in my book I choose to show
that Universal love through the actions
of other people you know um but it
didn't really matter who it was coming
from because I do believe that the
source is the same it's it's just our
human interconnectedness it's this love
that in psychedelics you see very
tangibly that God is love and that's the
current that's connecting us all and so
you can you just it's a choice to see it
or not see it mhm but there's no
framework maybe there is but not in my
mind yeah the truth that everything is
one like all the atoms are connected you
know the the we're mostly open space
this table our bodies the energy that we
share it's all a common singular thing
despite that truth it's impossible for
me to maintain that Sensibility
psychelic certainly we' proba be in a
better place as a planet and the culture
and whatever if we could if we could
really grock that um but I'm wondering
about and I know like advice like when
people ask you for advice you get you
start to cringe a little bit like you
have a discomfort with like telling
anyone what to do which I respect and
appreciate um but the person who's
suffering who
needs that healing and that message the
most is the most difficult person to
connect with because they're encased in
that shell with a certain narrative and
a painbody that makes it very difficult
where that's the person who will be the
first to dismiss anything that you would
have to say about this yeah and and but
I've also been that person MH and so
have I yeah and and that's the thing is
I and I wrote this with old me in
mind um because I knew what I would say
had I read certain lines in this book
you know only four or five years ago um
but I couldn't deny that that was the
truth that I found and I wasn't going to
filter myself because old me would have
torn it apart and and I know that my
book isn't for everyone because I know
it's not going to resonate with everyone
but someone who is suffering and without
love and lonely
um first of all can you find that love
inside yourself yeah right I mean in
moments of Despair you can't and I know
that because I've been that person but
as the Mal like the Mal ability of time
can you remember a memory of Love is
there something that tethers you to love
a moment even if it's a stranger um and
what did that feel like where did that
come from and and as a practice recog
choosing to recognize or remember those
memories maybe can lead you more to
seeing how love is all around us but or
just do a hero dois and you're like
you're like
Shing just Own It Steph that was
beautiful just like this is about you
standing in your power yeah I know yeah
that's what the book is about yeah don't
shy away from it yeah that was great
yeah well thank you I just why I I well
on my way here actually I was having
some selft talk about why do I have such
a hard time why do I have such a hard
time with advice I don't know I I'm
working on that I'll let you know I I do
too like I like to have conversations
with other people and ask them for
advice but then when people ask me for
advice I'm like why you asking me yeah
right yeah it's it's uncomfortable for
me and I'm trying to figure out why but
well I think a charitable interpretation
is it doesn't feel right to tell another
person what they should or they
shouldn't do you know that feels
like a close cousin to taking someone's
inventory yeah but the tension in The
Duality here is that you've had a
certain set of life experiences that
have taught you a few things that can be
helpful to others when imparted in the
right way and you're a vehicle for that
yeah the book does it it's not outright
saying do this don't do this but it's
saying here is an exper experience take
from it what you will and my hope is
that this will improve your life or
maybe give you a few things to think
about that can change your relationship
with whatever your experience is but
it's doing it in it's doing it and this
is like an AA thing it's like we don't
we don't tell people what to do we don't
give advice we share our experience
right this book is you sharing your
experience so you're comfortable doing
that yeah I'm very comfortable and so I
think that's healthy and maybe that's
just because this is the way I see it
too I want to feel like we got it right
it's not a deficiency yeah yeah
especially when you're online and you're
scrolling on Instagram or whatever and
people are like looking the camera and
they're telling you what to do there's
something very powerful about that that
people respond to but it also makes me
very UNC like I I don't think I'm the
right person to be like that you know
yeah well and also because I believe so
firmly that most truths are relative to
our own personal experiences so who am I
to say that this is is know my partner
has cancer what should I tell my kids
there supposed to be some general I'm
sure you can asked that question a lot
right yeah I do and I I don't respond
because I or I just stammer through some
kind of you know blanket statement
because I nobody wants to hear it
depends it depends do what you think is
right I mean no but I yeah it's just
everything and part of what I write in
my book is that truth is so it's like a
kaleidoscope it's just a Twist of the
risk depending on your perspective and
your experiences and my truth has
changed so much throughout my life and
again me reading this book I wrote 5
years ago wouldn't have resonated so I
think I just have to understand and
accept that my book The this book isn't
for everyone you know it's who is it for
well really for me and and the truth is
that's what an artist does yeah I wrote
it for me and even now reading it back I
see how a lot of what it will be
criticized for is because I wrote it for
me and I I didn't really think much
about other people reading it and
actually the night before it came out I
had a total meltdown because I was like
oh [__] people are going to paralyzing
but if yeah if you had thought about
that while you were writing you would
have edited yourself you can't do that
yeah it's it that's true and so I'm glad
it is raw the way it is because that's
what I that's the story I had to tell
myself for myself that is me making
sense of my life for me and if other
people can gain something from that
great but if not then I just have to be
okay with it being me bearing my soul
for myself nothing great is for
everybody yeah what yeah you know it's a
big world out there as Seth Goden says Y
and my hope for you is that 10 years
from now you'll revisit this book you'll
read it and in in perfect non-duality or
do Duality here there'll be part of you
who's really proud of you for having the
courage to tell this story and and being
able to like recognize the beauty in it
and another part of you is going to
cringe and say oh my God I can't believe
like I wrote that I already I know I
will cuz I'm already starting to be like
wow I really because you have grown
you've continued to grow and and you're
so you've transcended you know some of
the ideas that you were struggling with
when you wrote it absolutely y yep I
hope that for me too yeah I guess as a
final thing is there we covered a lot
but like I guess I feel responsible in
asking you like is there a core idea
beyond what we've already discussed
today that you were trying to express in
this book that we didn't cover I mean I
think we covered it just between the
lines but just self-acceptance and and
and that was what I was really trying to
do was accept myself throughout this
book is is right for me a narrative that
would allow myself to accept and make
sense of all of the recklessness and all
of the craziness and and accept it all
as the beauty that makes me me now and
that that couldn't have happened had I
not gone down all of the the dead ends
that I thought were dead ends which
we're really now looking at it were
probably like bridges too
myself and and so really it's just that
self-love and self-acceptance yeah again
it's that rear view thing like well when
I went to Guatemala you know all these
things that probably in the moment
you're like why am I doing this or what
am I doing with my life now seem
integral in you know building the person
that you are today I think the final
thing I wanted to ask you also was that
your relationship with shame you know
coming out of of the stri pictures of of
a religious upbringing and and then
being a rebel right like there there has
to be some residue of
like in that department of
self-love the other side of that is like
the Deep shame and unworthiness because
you're a bad person that that seeking
inside of you like just tell me I'm a
good person or how do I become a good
person yeah absolutely is a shame is a
response to that shame right an antidote
to that yeah I try really hard not to
well in shame because
shame is something I want my children to
rarely feel I know they can't come out
unscathed but shame is such a large part
of Christianity really and I've seen how
it it crippled me for a long time and a
lot of the people that I love and and I
really try not to embody shame because I
don't want my children especially as
three girls um to grow up and trying to
emulate that um I do think I think it's
ber Brown that said the difference
between guilt and shame and that guilt
is actually actionable and and I do have
guilt like when I read my book back I
feel guilty for poor Jane and she was
sober for six months and then I she got
drunk with me and I feel guilt for that
um and and I think guilt is just taking
responsibility but shame I feel like is
just a dead end there's no purpose for
shame it's just um yeah there's no
actionable purpose for it and so I I
think I want to teach my kids the
difference between those two things yeah
I think the Ripple to that is guilt I
think this is what BR said guilt is an
emotion around something you did and
shame is an emotion around who you are
yeah yeah exactly yeah but but in
religion they're so tightly inned I mean
you're taught that your actions are who
who you are you know that drinking makes
you a bad person in the Mormon religion
and and you really are taught that and
it's really ingrained and so trying to
separate those two um those two things
being you know what I do isn't
necessarily who I am and I think that
was also exemplified by that um the
bishop who told me you know I hear you
list off all of these quote unquote sins
but you're still a good person and that
right there I think that's the split
between you know action and what who you
are exactly and he wasn't exonerating
you from taking responsibility for it
yeah but he was distinguishing behavior
from Identity absolutely yeah yeah yeah
beautiful yeah I think we did it I think
we did it yeah um the book is fantastic
you're inspiring Tommy is inspiring you
together is is truly a you know one plus
one equals 10 um equation uh and uh I
just you know I wish you guys the best
and thank you um Tommy's continued
recovery and I hope to see both of you
in the future thank you what's coming
next for you are you into another book
or is it dayto day going from the gut is
it going to take 10 years for another
book well who knows I don't know I'm I
am already of course I already started
writing another book but it's not a
memoir it's not a memoir it's a novel so
we'll see where that goes yeah I think
I'm done with the the Memoir yeah well
you I think you got out to live a little
bit more life you know it's like one
year later my next me yeah no yeah but
in the interim yeah and then also like I
said just being just learning just to be
and maybe it's okay not to have another
project on the table I don't know we'll
see yeah yeah I can you're like your
your skin is crawling you know that
right as somebody who lives out of their
gut instinct you should be okay with
that I will I we'll see what happens
yeah well absolute delight and pleasure
to talk to so much everybody pick up the
book everything all at once at your
favorite book seller independent
bookstores hopefully if not Amazon they
should be everywhere your website I'll
link up all that stuff in the show notes
and uh come back and talk to me again
awesome thank you so much cheers
peace that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch
my books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcast on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director director Dan Drake
portraits by Davey Greenberg graphic and
social media assets courtesy of Daniel
CIS thank you Georgia Wy for copywriting
and website management and of course our
theme music was created by Tyler Patt
traper Patt and Harry mathys appreciate
the love love the support see you back
here soon peace plants
namaste
[Music]
he